joining us now for reaction in West Palm
Beach Florida is best-selling author and
Coulter and in New York Kathy aru who is
publisher of Catalina magazine it is
great to have two smart women on the
show all right Kathy yeah have at the
angle have it me I'm sure you disagree
with some of the things I said no in
other words not a word anyway you're
awesome okay but it wasn't a love fest
you said it's usually a love fest so
this year it wasn't just a love fest it
was beyond the lip service it was beyond
the padding on the back and Hollywood
got real so they were as real as what's
happening outside so for 90 years
they've left everything that's real
everything that's uncomfortable on the
outside of the theater and this year
they brought it in and if a little bit
of America was uncomfortable so be it
that's the way movements start that's
the way they continue and that's how
things change icon I consider it
progress and good for Hollywood they got
real
it's the all-time low in viewership for
the Uyghurs do we really watch do we
watch films and Oscars for them to opine
on politics I mean really smart people
out there but I think most people just
want to release from the nasty left
right you know what you know look I'm
sure I'm sure we're part of it but I
think people want to entertainment to
escape some of it at least
and I think when when these actors and
celebrities just marinate themselves in
politics I mean you can watch us you can
watch other networks for that and I know
you were glued to your television set
last night
I have to say I didn't watch one
millisecond of the Oscars I had a kid
with the flu and went to bed early but
go ahead fantastic we have the perfect
panel to discuss the Oscars because I
didn't even know they were on and didn't
watch them however I did have a friend
from the industry calling in like every
half an hour to give me the political
updates and I did look up a few videos
later so so I do I am an expert now and
one thing that was funny about it is I
mean this was supposed to be the big me
two Oscars but it very quickly ones
off the rails and you know all these
women who've been raped and pawed and
and had their careers destroyed like
Mira Sorvino I mean she's a real hero
who should have been celebrated no that
was pushed aside so we can talk about
transgenders and illegals and immigrants
no in intersectionality we got
intersectionality in there and as for
you I mean your opening statement no
you're giving you're giving most
celebrities I think really fantastic
advice and and they can take it from
from people like us I had I had a an
actor sort of making fun of me once very
famous actor whom I won't name and you
know sneering at me because people come
up to me on the street and you know say
mean things to me and I said yeah
everybody says nice things to you
they're talking about your character at
least when people love me it's really
money a big loss but you know you and I
and I guess all three of us I'm sorry I
don't know you Kathy it but you're in
politics if you're in politics you're
gonna have half the country hate you
there's nothing you can do about it
but if you are a skier like someone I
used to love Lindsey Vonn haha was so
happy when she lost or you know these
actors and actresses you can have the
whole world loved you wouldn't not be
great yes water do you bother leaping
out and taking a political position that
are taking off half of the country but
it's admirable they're choosing to do so
which is admirable they're no longer
just giving like I said the lip service
we can't criticize them anymore for just
hiding behind their characters they're
showing we are intelligent we're not
just these bimbos we play we're not
these characters we play we are
intelligent women we could be
cinematographers we could be directors
look at all these roles look at what we
can do and they have the women stand up
and they did explain each role that
women play behind the cameras that I
mean most Americans aren't aware of I
think we're just happy yeah Cathy do you
think most Americans care about the
gender or the race or the ethnicity of
the cinematographer don't they just care
about whoever makes it and whoever's
great at it the beauty of it is most of
not care about gender and
really confused because I think I
thought we were supposed to get away
from gender race and sexual everyone is
the same now everybody's not the same no
we have to we have to bean count in
every profession and heaven forbid
you're a white male and you're a
cinematographer because you must have
totally screwed someone over to get your
job I'm sorry to be harsh there but I
think if you're a white male in
Hollywood you probably have a target on
your back given the the atmosphere out
there which I think sometimes doesn't
doesn't give due process to people poor
Ryan Seacrest I mean I'm not I don't
even know want Ryan Seacrest but he was
like the persona non-grata last night
after he was cleared as far as I can
tell of any wrongdoing in any case but
now nobody will go up to him like he's a
leper like why's that but that's how
movements start I mean the other Oscars
were so 89 Oscars ago I mean this is a
90th this is a new time the next 90
years we are gonna care more about
genders we are gonna care about these
things that's the whole point this is a
turning point when a second time care
they're telling us we have to care we
have to care okay well guys I want to
play one soundbite that's really I think
really positive Garry Oldham who won for
of course the darkest hour playing
Churchill this is what he said when he
won the award I owe this and so much
more to so many I have I've lived in
America for the longest time and I am
deeply grateful to her for the loves and
the friendships I have made and the many
the many wonderful gifts it has given me
my my home my livelihood my family
I'm not asking and he was a Drudge had
this big thing up all day that he was
trashed on social media he looks social
media social media but he was trashed
because I guess of again past
allegations against him where you see
all these people sitting in the audience
last night who knew Harvey Weinstein was
an abuser who knew he had refused Bob
rape and they're sitting there and like
because they have a ribbon on or because
they gave a speech suddenly that
three decades at Harvey Weinstein was
destroying people's lives is all somehow
washed away no I really I don't want to
move on from this point that this is the
year of me too I mean a lot of very
important people and some were heroes
like Brad Pitt who stood up to Weinstein
on behalf of of Gweneth Paltrow and
again Mira Sorvino had her career
destroyed if it yeah it's very strange
they just go off into all the
politically correct stuff I thought that
was a lovely acceptance speech and I'd
like to contrast it with Guillermo del
Toro's who talked about how we have to
have a borderless world and I'm happy I
got the co but I was boarding well well
we wanted to point is he didn't mention
that the reason he didn't go back to
Mexico for 15 years was that his father
was kidnapped and held for ransom for
several years until he got someone to
provide $1,000,000 so he better hope
that wall gets built alright back to
Mexico now moved his whole family here
maybe truth in advertising and I just
want to say quickly about what guys
showing their intelligence they're
showing they are bimbo all right both of
you are smart women very accomplished in
your own right we really appreciate your
joining us tonight